oh
[Musique]
salez brut
place des fêtes plage et off
[Musique]
ces quartiers qui m'a fait donc ma
musique je sais pas comment tu vois mes
expressions ma façon de parler la
manière d'aborder même c'est quand tu tu
comptes étaient plus enfin rap de deuil
aux tripes et tous les choses que tu dis
les noms que tu cites c'est c'est ses
propres aux 19e et et ce qui inspire ans
les personnalités que tu pouvais tu peux
y rencontre tu te rencontrer il ya du
lourd ce ça les gens les plus lourds
sont pas les plus célèbres mais les gens
et du célèbre ne s'inspire que ce genre
a donc dans le 19ème et à des
personnalités connues de tous les gens
qui sont très inspirante
ils font partie des gens qui m'ont
inspiré
[Musique]
montella
dans mon quartier il ya un cri ça fait
et tous ceux qui tous ceux qui entendent
ce cri savent que c'est à dire du 10 de
danube
bref c'est étrange et si tu fais ça
c'est que tu n'as 19 ya ça il ya
longtemps il ya une manière de
s'habiller
nous on cuir noir courent élue elle
serait du quartier 501 et petites
chaussures blanches et chaussures ça te
fait demander par tout ça vient 19e
j'ai commencé à rapper à 20 ans mais
avant de rappeler j'ai dansé
j'ai beaucoup dessiner beaucoup dessiner
à l'époque où ce fait important dessinée
et donc j'ai toujours été dans un milieu
de l'aj depuis l'âge de 11 ans et je me
rappelle que vers l'âge de 12 13 ans
j'allais déjà dans les mains des
concours de graff des compétitions dans
ce tout seul 12 ans parce que même temps
compare ça à la la passion des joues et
tu vois quand on était potes vous avez
dix ans et ya un nouveau jeu qui vient
de sortir
vous allez voir en magasin ou jette
comme des fous ben en ai joué moi je te
dis pas d'accord j'ai pas de monter avec
migros à ben j'avais tout seul sont tes
propos soit tu es partie du passé soit
et à l'heure
très simple moi c'est comme ça que j'ai
placé gens ce qui arrive sûrement avec
des clichés des années 90 c'est très
bien qu'ils font partie du passé le plus
chez les savoirs parce que si je
commence à entrer dans le débat
je les rejoindrai ans a fait ça
m'intéresse pas moi je kiffe cette
époque comme un dingue c'est ce que je
dis souvent c'est que ça valait le coup
d'attendre
parce que c'était inespéré peut pas dire
à un joueur plein de gens qui ont été
durables
tous les genevois des concerts et des
salles ben c'est impensable
impensable amara donc moi je suis comme
un dingue
[Musique]
je connais toujours avec des gens et des
pages allant soirée et y avait ma photo
nadine que j'ai dédicaces tout le temps
parce que c'est la faute aux nazis qui
m'a fait connaître des gens du milieu et
qui m'a demandé de lui écrire des textes
et et de là c'est parti
j'essaie d'écrire pour voir ça a plu et
j'ai continué c'est juste way et ça
assez j'ai pas hésité à faire parce que
plein de fois je me suis retrouvé sur
scène dans des concerts et je voyais les
mecs je me disais mais ça ça je peux le
faire ça sera très dur
en effet c'est pas très dur c'est tout
ce qu'il ya autour qui est dur c'est
tout ce qui emmène à son bras
quand tu commences à rappeler aussi
tirer toujours de son quartier quand tu
peux marcher à faire quand je commence à
évoluer toujours toujours fous avant
j'étais interne de tennis ici et pas de
rien de tout ça c'est très vague
c'est fou et non quand tu te sens tu
sutton toi.ca faire d'études son petit
chez quand tu as un quartier pourquoi je
le sais aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
si tu cristallise tous les sens tu as
mme qu'on peut se faire sur la réussite
alors qu'était qu'un chanteur avec un
chanteur qui fait du bruit en ce moment
mais pour qui rien et promis mais dans
l'endroit où tu es c'est un truc de ouf
de faire du voyage ce point là tu vois
qu'on parle de toi au travail qu'on
parle de thouars et donc tu va
cristalliser toutes les frustrations et
tous les fantasmes mais sur toi tout
seul et il ya du bien il ya du très
difficile et le très difficile fait
souvent que les artistes tombe
immédiatement après la célébrité et et
des s'éloigner physiquement va avec ce
qu'on appelle la réussite rend sa
logique légitime et quand tu reviens on
est toujours contents de me voir
[Musique]